I did intentionally give this a really
really broad kind of I didn't limit you
at all so I think that the bed day
resident me it was that one yeah what
does my face Trebek
we have worked at there diagrams this
particular topic and there's a reason
why have a look at the whole is I think
yeah I think it is the actual only one
which in this case is unique the rest of
things in some way shape or form since
they've a good way I saw some way shape
or form you can compare between right so
for example so many you could do it a
dot plot right what might is on top
would like something like this different
scores down the bottom view right and
then the number of people who scored
that particular those right you could
just as easily have drawn that dot plot
over there as a column graph right or
column graph or even a line graph or a
pie chart there's some amount of
interchangeability between points right
so I'm sorry Jacob what what I'm
actually going to just temporarily if I
kept you to have a little bit but here's
what I want to point out you guys are
the vintage on every single item on this
list every single one sorry because
they're all interchangeable what they
share in common but reason why they are
interchangeable is they all tend to talk
about a single known so for example
maybe you have a library maybe what it
charts is like temperature right it's
like all these different temperatures
from different days maybe you've got a
box plot what it tells you is by the way
five things go into a box pop one of the
five things what's the bottom there's a
minute before the law put a death
benefit then there's the next and then
you go in you get the quartiles and then
the video
but all of those all of those are like
well the median temperature and the
upper quartile for temperature or scores
or whatever so in that each of these
really talks about one values we call
this here's a new word for you and
wonder if you can tell me what it is I
love how people involuntarily read
things that are on the board I could
have written anything you'd be like blah
blah blah blah oh you ready don't you
look at the wedding you tell me what
does it mean yeah variable one variable
can you write that down for me please
that's what gives me one no now this is
extremely restrictive extremely
extremely shaken because often Ellen
sorry thank you
often we actually have more than just
one variable one value that we're
interested in frequently we're
interested in comparing different things
in relation to each other
so for example that idea to you as a
little subheading can you write me
underneath your list
comparing variables now I want you to
think for a moment I've shown anything
out just in the quietness of your body
how to think about a time when you might
be interested not just in working on a
single number but maybe a pair of
numbers that are related to each other
just people
is there time where you go situation
where you record more than one thing
about a person or a situation and where
it's useful to you to compare these two
things or think about them at the same
time I think everything right what do
you think you brought to sports what's
the variables you the all clear
well you've got two teams you can
compare the different like down between
okay now let's take this idea I want to
explore it a little bit depends I
remember I said this unit very does
right we've got stem and leaf tortilla
do you remember the little what would
something like this you've got your
number like a casual week four five six
seven eight and then what about starting
those herbs what are these look like
what do you have over here to my head
zone yeah I'll be like forty one second
sorry I know that
what if it's made that's all depend on
our DJ's 41 52 GTA v so this is we
noticed every pub looks like what do you
remember we looked at things like this
to it 24 what did this be we call these
back-to-back because for example you
might be comparing two different teams
or like boys and girls or chair broken
Castle fuel
you have letting people okay uh would
you get the GG okay it's a shame prices
going down but the point I was making
was you can compare two different teams
but you can compare them on my marital
for example the scores that they get per
game right or how fast they can run so
just because you've got two teams
doesn't mean you have more than one
variable let me give you any good
hi think about your face right maybe you
want to compare it something like they
should think about this for a month okay
this is two variables one two right
but one person can have both of these
variables right maybe I'm interested in
your height and your shoe size together
and everyone types in everyone change
sizes okay now take give me another
example of two things that can be
related to the same people but you want
to think about together have a good
weather outside can you think of some
weather variables where you've got more
than one figure you want to compare
their yes easy what is the great measure
just one let you compare temperature
week you great
do you see here I have more than one
variable and I want their what works is
going to be the same time so this is
clearly no longer do you know variate
data all the examples are rc4 we've been
comparing two pieces are so what do you
think will reproduce look you need like
we've got unicycles and your one wheel
we're calling it to this area my tickle
rush to say double donut cycle
these guys very chic yeah you can okay
these guys over here we call not
univariate data box my variant I'm fine
okay so you have two variable change
interested in book okay
now the tool of choice on this whole big
retiree of different things that you can
use the tool of choice to represent
bivariate data easier heading into a
corner scatter coin scanner for